thank you very much for the introduction
for the possibility to speak here and
give this this lecture I hope that in an
hour or so less than an hour this title
will have become clear I want to show
you some sort of basic statistics and
how it is used and reflected in
biological applications but not only
biological the reason why I picked this
is because it's really quite important
in a whole number of fields because the
thinking is absolutely generic much of
the work I'm not going to speak much
about our own research a little bit but
the whole topic was shaped in our group
in discussions with his students Jana
pan and MRSA Gandhari and the postdoc
Julia hacer and several of the slides
actually are stolen from them so I owe
them a lot for this those for those of
you who are not really into biology a
quick rehash I think this is now more or
less common common knowledge the the a
chromosome is made up of DNA that is
composed of the four basic elements a
cgt abbreviated and there's genes on a
chromosome and the genes code via a
messenger and for proteins and the
proteins basically do the work in the
sales and in our body the the fact that
these genes get transcribed is under
regulation so not every gene on our
chromosome is transcribed all the time
then I think there would be a grower
growth shortage of space in the average
sale but there is very strict regulation
as to which genes get transcribed and
the proteins expressed at what point in
time and under what circumstances and
part of the machinery that regulates
this is a subclass of proteins which are
called the transcription factor
we usually use TF is an abrogation that
so there are particular genes encoded in
the genome which code for transcription
factors and the transcription factors in
turn control other genes that control
the transcription of other genes that's
why they are called transcription
factors so we can think of a chain
hierarchy of events and in the cell i
already said there's a number of
proteins in the cell and nowadays it is
still technologically very difficult to
measure the amount of an individual
protein in a cell but what is much more
accessible is the amount of a given
messenger RNA that's this intermediate
between the gene that's encoded on the
chromosome and the protein and as a
result of these measurement techniques
which will measure here the messenger
RNA rather than the protein you can
think of the cell as a collection of
mRNA molecules and here the mRNA
molecules of the same color are intended
to signify that they come from the same
G and they are expressed in different
strengths or levels so some of them are
lonely expressed and others will be very
abundant in the cell and it's now about
20 years that we have technology to
measure these abundances that started in
the 90s with the micro arrays nowadays
we have a technique that's called RNA
seek but for the purpose of this this
talk now it doesn't matter where the
data comes from in the end we have our
mathematical abstraction we have a
matrix with expression levels of the
individual genes where g12 whatever our
is our genes yeast has six thousand
genes we have about 20,000 genes so
that's the order of magnitude that we're
talking about when it comes to genes and
we have measured the contents of the
cell under different conditions or
different cell types you can think of
you can think of different cells in your
body like muscle cells brain cells liver
skin whatever and each each of those
cell types would be one row here
it's often we oftentimes speak of the
samples that we have available and the
distribution of the genes will be
different in each of these samples so we
are entering our way towards the
abstract formulation of a problem let's
say these are two genes here each of
these columns corresponds to one gene
and we have many samples and read and
the one is a high and low so the I can
immediately pick out that there's some
kind of anti correlation between those
jeans just from the color coding here
and that really reflects the intuition
that we have that that since the
transcription factors can activate or
also repress other genes there's
associations between the genes that we
can tell from the abundances so the
columns are those abundances and we want
to tell what the associations are so
here it's called the observation vectors
and really what we want to determine is
whether between g1 and g2 there is some
kind of relationship or there's no
relationship between them so in an
abstract sense we think of these nodes
here is representing random variables
and these are samples from these random
variables which correspond to the two
genes of course we think that in indore
cell in the reality there are more or
less complicated relationships yeah one
transcription factor will turn on a
number of genes one of which is again a
transcription factor this gene may be
under the control of this one as well as
of this one and this one together with
this other one will have an effect on
yet another one and so on so this is the
type of network interactions which we
would like to recover only from this
data matrix that has been measured
so I said that about 20 years ago the
technology was developed to perform
these measurements and here is a quote
from a paper in two thousand maybe you
have made the same experience with your
students that before 2000 there was no
scientific literature so this is from
year zero of scientific literature and
that was a became pretty well-known this
paper in our field discovering
functional relationships that's what
I've been talking about here it's not
within the set of genes but it's between
RNA expression and chemotherapeutic
susceptibility using relevance networks
relevance networks was also a term that
was I think point in this paper and it
is worth reading this comprehensive
pairwise correlations were calculated
between gene expression and measures of
age and susceptibility associations
weaker than a threshold were removed
leaving networks of highly correlated
genes and agents called the relevance
networks sounds very straightforward we
do all the correlation coefficients
among all these vectors that we saw
before and whenever this is not zero the
on are larger than some threshold we
draw an edge and that's the network and
this is a figure from this paper this is
what the result looks like you can see
they obviously do networks for fairly
large number of genes and they have 60
cancer cell lines so you have a 60
measurement per gene and this gives rise
to this network after selecting a
particular threshold and when you look
at this sort of in a more systematic way
here we have again this matrix the
columns are these measurements all the
measurements for individual genes and in
this example say the blue and this funny
greenish color also have a nonzero
interaction and that is represented by
nature and in particular there is no
edge when we deem the correlation
efficient to be zero or of course in
reality it's never zero but it's just
very small so we always have to select
some threshold below which we we do not
draw an edge here so what's the problem
with this well in the world of jeans
this is fairly easy to say suppose we
have one gene that activates another
gene and that gene in turn activates a
third one we will see this in the data
hopefully but the data will also make it
appear to us as if the rotor
relationship between gene one and three
yeah because we have a good correlation
between the first two so here's a quote
from another paper we are now 11 years
later it's not really about gene
networks it's about residue interactions
but the mathematics here is the same
firstly offers say that the covariance
or correlation based analysis so the
networks that I was just telling you
about has a problem because of what it
says here residue belonging to partner
proteins of this pathway was found a
partial predict tricked into protein
really country but also many residue
pairs which are far apart a major
shortcoming of covariance analysis is
that correlations between substitution
patterns of interacting residues in use
secondary correlations between
non-internet communities so they have
pinpointed the problem and they are
developing methodology to take care of
this problem and to eliminate these
secondary correlations so in the
statistical literature these secondary
correlations have actually been dealt
with not 20 years ago but about a
hundred years ago and what the statistic
literature does is they introduce the
partial correlation coefficient exactly
for that reason and what the partial
correlation coefficient does is this
here we have it in the same color code
we first take one variable say the blue
one and regress the one variable with
respect to say the green and the the
brownish one here are in grey scion you
on the remaining variables we also
regrese the red one if we want to
determine the relationship between blue
and red on the remaining set of
variables and that way we obtain two
sets of residuals so this is a
regression now vs. you can think of it
versus a plane of these two variables
that are left and you have all these
errors and you regress these error
vectors between the two regressions that
were done in here and a partial
correlation is defined what a shame okay
the partial correlation is defined as
the coordination between these victims
of residuals it's a very straightforward
to finish and that as I said is about
the hundred years old why would you do
that yeah why would you do that let's
think about this motivating example
again where that I used to explain that
there's a problem with these transitive
interactions suppose I do the regression
from one to two are and from two to
three each time I make an error and
these vectors of errors don't know about
each other they have nothing to do with
each other yeah what about the
regression from one to three which
happens to be our induced one when i
look at the residual of the regression
from one to three and compared to the
residual of the regression from one to
two
part of the information is the same
because two is halfway towards three so
these are not independent these know
about each other yeah likewise this red
set of residuals with a set of residuals
from here and this is the inside behind
this definition so what does one do it's
the same philosophy we have these
columns here and now we compute the
partial correlations and that will
hopefully tell us that say this
particular edge here is superfluous
because it's induced by the two other
ones and building networks from partial
correlations nowadays goes by the name
of Gaussian awful models and that's part
of what what one now learns in a class
on graphical models but I promised you
that I would also talk about the
variance covariance matrix and its
inverse so how does that come into play
what is the connection with the variance
covariance matrix this is our data
situation here this matrix here has say
the genes now actually I swapped the
dimensions the jeans are here and the
columns are now the conditions and
that's the typical situation in biology
where we have thousands of genes but
since for every condition sample
graduate student has to do an experiment
there is a very small number of
experiments in the very small number of
columns here and to get the variance
covariance matrix we multiply this data
matrix with its transpose and then we
get the variance covariance matrix at
least under suitable normalization that
was done beforehand so our variance
covariance matrix is this product here
the classical correlation coefficient
that we know from school can be
expressed as an entry in the variance
covariance matrix / the geometric mean
of this I i and j JJ entries that's a
sort of classical front and we do that
and that was implicit in the definition
of the relevance net
work we do that because when this
correlation coefficient is zero the two
variables are stochastically independent
what about the partial correlation
coefficient I said the partial
correlation is the correlation of the
residual vector upon regressing both x
and y to the remaining variables the
remaining variables are here witnessed
this boldface z I also said this is
about 100 years old it started with a
long-ish discussion between pearson and
you that began a little bit before
nineteen hundred and stretched on and it
was all under the headline of and i
won't use the word anyway afterwards it
was all under the headline of finding
causal relationships because when you
when people are looking for causality
rather than correlation they want to
know whether a correlation could be due
to another cause and that led to the
development of the partial correlation
coefficient Fisher then worked on it and
distribute and then computed the
statistical distribution and sort of the
canonical definition is in this early
version of Kendall statistical Theory
where you were still involved and what
the correlation coefficient correlation
coefficient does mathematically is it
uses not the variance covariance matrix
but it uses the inverse of the variance
covariance matrix so now let's call the
elements of the inverse variance
covariance matrix little p and then this
is the definition for the partial
correlation coefficient with respect to
the set of remaining variables so a set
of vertices V without I and J and you
see it has the same shape except that
the P now is not the element of the
variance covariance matrix itself but
it's an element of the inverse of the
variance covariance matrix so all this
business of correlations and partial
correlations can very elegantly be
expressed in terms of the variance
covariance matrix
why do we do it we had the the the the
the basic theorem about correlations
that 0 coronation amounts to stochastic
independence for the partial correlation
is 0 partial correlation coefficient
amounts to conditional independence
given a set of variable this is the
definition of definition of conditional
independence it's it's kind of an
intricate thing when you think about it
I'll give an example right away so you
see it's very parallel to the classical
theorem about correlations and it also
tells us what we are really doing when
we do these networks if we want to avoid
the transitive edges the induced edges
we don't look at the variance covariance
matrix we don't look at the correlation
coefficients but we look at the inverse
of the variance covariance matrix and we
exclude those edges where the partial
correlation coefficient is more or less
zero and that's the theory behind the
Gaussian graphical models so here's an
example this figure was made by by one
of the students I mentioned in the
beginning it is really I really got me
started on preparing preparing this set
of slides because I like this figure so
much and they wanted to do a talk around
this figure so we have a number of the
say genes any kinds of variables X 1 to
X 4 now suppose they are linked in this
kind of chain and what what Giuliana the
student did at the time for her
presentation was she prepared a
simulation where the first column comes
from a standard normal distribution the
second column is a transformation of the
first one where x1 enters into another
normal distribution so the second one is
derived from the first one likewise the
third is derived from the second one and
the fourth is derived from the third one
that's why it's changing
so based on this we get this table of
covariances among those four variables
and you can see that all elements are
filled there is no zero element here so
the covariances make it appear as if the
network of these four variables would be
fully linked because somehow there is a
correlation between everything when we
go on and we invert this matrix all of a
sudden the zeros appear and the zeros
are exactly for those edges which are
only induced edges like x1 to x3 doesn't
exist it's only induced by chaining
these generative laws together and
that's why in the inverse of the
variance covariance matrix this edge
disappears and becomes zero you can also
see that you get you can recover exactly
the factors that were put into the laws
here so when you make no edge where
there's a 0 in the inverse of the
variance covariance matrix you can
precisely recover the chain according to
which the data were generated so here
the independence holds but in the
inverse what holds is the conditional
independence for the zero entries and
conditional independence now is easier
to understand like 1 & 4 are
conditionally independent because if you
know x2 and x3 it uncouples them and
then they are then they look independent
but not in the presence of x2 and x3 so
bottom line the recipe to compute
networks from this type of data is an
extremely simple one you invert the
variance covariance matrix with the
variance covariance matrix only being
the data by its transpose nothing else
that's usually called often called the
precision matrix or concentration matrix
and the networking has no edge whenever
the m3 of the precision matrix is zero
and we hope that that way we have no
transitive effect so quick simulation on
this this was the network that we saw in
the beginning one simulates data
according to some law and then if this
was the adjacency matrix of this network
and the dark entries is where there is
an edge this is the input data and when
we try to reconstruct it after
simulating and adding noise what we get
looks like this we have this little
square up here that is recovered we have
this hoop here that we see but yellow
yellow is is fairly small number so we
see that things start to depend on where
where we would set the threshold for
what it means to be 0 but in principle
the hook here is visible likewise here
and this checkerboard pattern down here
is also visible in the reconstruction so
the method works at least on a
simulation amazingly well here's an
example and I was just trying to give
you a impression that people do use this
on biological data although once you
start to really work on biological data
there's always various odds and ends
that one has to take into account this
figure is taken from the work of these
guys costella and over 80 who have a
program at a number of papers that
follow the philosophy but are much more
refined than what I've been showing here
however there's a number of problems
that one has to be aware of especially
for the applications in biology I
already pointed out to you that in
biology people frequently wanted to
compute networks for many many genes
although based on a fairly small amount
of data because the data have to be
generated so here's the result of
simulations where we we generated a
network that has 15 nodes the data are
strictly Gaussian I didn't even add
noise to it here now so it's really
just to confirm the theory and the rough
curves are to be understood such that
since we generated the data we have a
gold standard network and when we
reconstruct we can sort by the absolute
value of the partial correlation
coefficient and then we can do a ROC
curve and see how easy is it to get back
to correct edges from the gold standard
and you see it depends a lot on the
sample size yeah 50 nodes if I have
fewer samples the nodes 30 samples this
is the ROC curve so we're making a quite
quite a few errors here 70 samples is
green a hundred samples is red and 300
samples obviously is enough data to
really make it very very clear to the
program what the original Network looked
like I have to sort of make one one
remark on that which has nothing to do
with this particular topic but
unfortunately has a lot to do with
genomics and bioinformatics and that is
the slippery slope towards towards
scientific misconduct and fraud this was
one simulation whenever I do this with a
new simulation new random data it looks
very different I actually did it like 10
20 times until I had an example that I
could really use here for didactic
purposes the proper way to do it of
course would have been to run I did a
hundred times and do this with means and
the error bars and all that yeah but as
it stands here it's almost fraudulent
now you very rarely get such beautiful
pictures but still I mean to drive the
point home there's another catch here
that I want to point out I I was
basically trying to to bang the
classical choral correlation coefficient
into the ground so what happens if we do
this with a classical correlation
coefficient and not inverting the
variance covariance matrix
looks even better yeah so what is going
on why am I telling you all this what
this says is the sorting of the ages is
still good yeah but we need to have to
eventually take a decision which edges
in the network are real and which are on
the induced edges so when we look at the
distribution of the classical
correlation coefficient and that the
distribution of the partial correlation
coefficient in the partial correlation
coefficient we have the set of edges
that have a very very high almost one
currently one correlation original
almost one and all this is zero and
there are sort of a little bit of a
twilight zone here in the classical
correlation coefficient you can tell
that it would be extremely difficult to
decide where to have a threshold for
which edges to leave out so there's much
more of a smear here on the way towards
the good correlation coefficients so
this is really the point the partial
correlation coefficients must disappear
for these transitively in used edges and
here we get a very clear view of the
edges that we don't want whereas here
it's much more difficult to come up with
the threshold I also wanted to
communicate to you that this is really
this is so simple and so generic that
obviously it must be very very hard to
come up with totally new ways to think
about network reconstruction so one can
go through the literature and it's
fairly sobering to see how many novel
methods eventually return to what I've
been telling you yeah so here's one
example and it's actually it's a very
good example because i think it drives
home the points that that we just
discussed this was a paper much
discussed
years one half of this very intense
discussion came from here I think from
Berkeley it's the paper which Lea Parton
menorahs Kelly's were arguing about but
what I'm going to talk about has nothing
to do with their blog it's about a
different aspect of this the papers got
network deconvolution as a general
method to distinguish direct dependence
in networks so direct dependencies that
has concerned us now all this half an
hour that I've been talking so far and
he produced he puts forward Network
deconvolution and the thinking is neat
he says the data that we actually get in
biology they stem from the following
process so genes influence each other
and when we collect the data we also
collect the transitively induced
consequences of the original
interactions and we are interested only
in the original interactions so in graph
theoretical language he says this graph
is the transitive closure of that graph
and what I would really want to do is I
want to go backward invert the
transitive closure he calls it
deconvolution and get the original edges
which had given rise to the data that I
measured and he makes the following need
observation he says our observed data so
the the data matrix that we collect is
the product of the original direct
interactions and then of course the sort
of first order transitive ages you can
express as the square of the adjacency
matrix of the graph so the original
direct age is plus the square of the
original interactions then you have a
next order transitively induced edges
those are the cube of the original
adjacency matrix and if you fully close
this transitive closure process
you need to add up an infinite sum here
so that's what what one learns in school
and if only if only number is small
enough then i have this inversion
formula for the for this series and this
is x times x divided by 1 minus X so for
graphs it would be the the matrix G
direct times the inverse of identity
minus G direct yeah the whole did the
whole debate then was about the
convergence properties under what
circumstances does it does it converge
and so on but this is the thinking and
in order to recover the original data
the direct interactions the the authors
of this paper simply solve this little
equation and achieve then they arrive at
this formula here the observed data
times the inverse of identity plus the
observed data so a very neat formula so
now let's try to link this to the
variance covariance matrix the data that
we compute that we that we measure I
already try to convince you we have a
measurement matrix and usually as the
similarity measure on the genes people
use the correlation coefficient other
covariance so in essence if we would
assume that the data is normalized and
in our case now here also are
standardized to a standard deviation of
one then we can just express it again
the similarity matrix as data matrix x
transpose of the data matrix and we have
a variance covariance matrix again and
now the authors of that paper they have
one little remark they say well self
loops make no sense yeah we want one
gene to influence another gene so what
they do in the program is they set the
main diagonal of the observed data to
zero if I would if I do this
normalization and standardization what
that amounts to is that I take my
variance covariance matrix and the main
diagonal of this will be one
and when i subtract the identity matrix
that's how they say that they compute
the matrix of observed similarity values
now let's put this here into the formula
this was the formula g observed is now
variance covariance matrix minus
identity so do you observed is sigma
minus identity and when i put sigma
minus identity into this parenthesis
here i have plus the identity minus
identity disappears the inversion goes
here and then i multiply the inverse
various conveyance programs matrix onto
this and in the end i'm left with the
identity matrix minus the inverse of the
variance covariance matrix so if you now
forget the the identity their whole
procedure amounts to inverting the
variance covariance matrix and that's
what I meant to say it is very hard to
come up with a totally new method
because this variance covariance
business is so fundamental that it just
solves the problem so in reality i
glossed over a whole lot of really hard
problems you may have heard of the P
much larger than n problem this is what
has been driving the development of
statistics and computational biology for
the last 10 15 years this is the shape
of our data we have n conditions and P
genes and they're already pointed out to
you that there's a certain imbalance
when they want to infer information on
many many relationships among genes from
fairly small amount of data and
mathematically you can see this
apparently in the fact that when i
multiply this matrix with its transpose
the rank of this matrix will be way
below the size of the matrix the rank
will typically be in if it's not n minus
1 or n minus 2 which it could also be
but it cannot be more than n yeah that's
the maximum
of rank for this large matrix here so
again we have kind of an information
problem you know the matrix only
pretends to contain a lot of information
but doesn't in reality because it
doesn't have full rank it has way less
so what would we do in this situation
here yeah how can we remedy so option
one the more statistically inclined
about you will know about shrinkage
methods may be actually the first thing
that you say is oh I know how to invert
singular matrices yeah we can use a
Penrose inverse we can use the singular
value decomposition that's not a problem
yes all these things are doable they do
not work particularly well the set of
shrinkage methods works quite well and
there is a group of methods which use
the Assumption well-founded assumption
that we don't want so many edges in our
network so what we want is we want this
Paris network meaning we want many zeros
in the inverse of the variance
covariance matrix so to compute the
inverse of the variance covariance
matrix in the way such that there will
be many zeros there so those are these
Paris inversion records that's all very
interesting stuff actually since I had
the luxury to spend time here I've I did
a lot of reading on this in the last
couple of months but then there's the
other option work on another problem
yeah and this is what we've been doing
we looked at chromatin data why look at
chromatin data chromatin data turns the
data situation around so let me explain
how that works what is chromatin in
eukaryotic genomes we are eukaryotes for
example in eukaryotic genomes the DNA is
tightly wound in-into little knots in
ourselves the reason probably being that
otherwise the volume that the DNA would
take up would exceed possible volume of
itself
so in order to really compact the huge
amount of DNA that we have that we have
this very intricate mechanism of
compacting it so the DNA is wound around
the set of proteins in the middle and
this whole thing is called in nuclear
zone and the set of proteins here in the
middle they are called histones several
of them they have part of the Jane chain
dangling out of this complex and there
are little chemical moieties attached to
these chains these are the so called
histone modifications and there's a
whole number of different chemical
modifications and according leaders and
there are many different histone
modifications people have studied on the
order of 3040 such histone modifications
probably there's more out there and
people also observed that the histone
modifications in the regions where the
gene start in the promoters have a
relationship to the expression of the
genes they are somehow involved in the
regulation so for example what do we
have here histone 3 that's one of these
proteins lysine 4 so interesting the
amino acid lysine is abbreviated with K
lysine 4 trimethylation is very strong
in the promoter region that's the
beginning of the gene and is positively
correlated to the prostitute to the
induction of the gene to its expression
that's one such example and in the
recent years people have determined the
levels of these histone modifications in
the genome for many different cell types
so this k562 is a sale time H realize
the for mono methylation is one of the
histone modifications and this is the
amount of this modification along the
DNA up here we have a gene the
transcription starts here so this
particular modification is present not
only here in the
beginning of the gene but also in what
we say the gene body these other one H
realized for trimethylation I just
pointed out to you that this is
connected to transcription and it tends
to be high at the beginning of the gene
in a promoter h3k4 trimethylation we see
exactly here in the promoter region and
then it disappears again the same holds
true for this k27 acetylation and here
something is totally absent this 27
trimethylation is traditionally seen as
a hallmark of repression of EG if we
would have a peek here the gene would be
often would not be transcribed but the
other situation is the one that we
observe here the activating marks are on
and the repressive mark is off so you
can already tell these relationships
also among the diff different histone
modifications so what we started to do
as these data appeared we started to ask
questions about what is the relationship
among the different histone
modifications how can we how can we
approach this so this is now an entire
genome it contains consists of three
genes each gene has sort of the gene
body from where the messenger RNA is
transcribed and it has a regulatory
region that's the promoter in this
regulatory region in our case it was the
laboratory of kg tau from the National
Cancer Institute in Bethesda has
determined around 30 different histone
modifications so we we basically look at
this region here and we sum up or we
compute the integral under this curve
here in the promoter region that's the
meaning of summing the tags in the
promoters so we get one number per
histone modification and promoter and
that means a vector of like 30
modifications per promoter here
now let's look at the data situation in
this problem we have a small number of
histone modifications and the thousands
of genes in an organism each one has a
promoter so we have a huge number of
promoters available so we have solved
our data shortage problem we have enough
data now to actually compute the
variance covariance matrix and also
compute its inverse our P by P matrix
now the P is much smaller than n and we
don't need to fight me to P much larger
than n problem anymore so here is the
correlations among the different histone
modifications and you can see for
example up here correlation coefficient
of one is almost white here up here is a
cluster of highly correlated histone
modifications and here we see this h3
lysine 27 acetylation which is a
hallmark of the activation of a gene so
all these are correlated with the
activity of the gene whereas down here
we have the 27 trimethylation which is
the hallmark of repression so this whole
cluster down here is a cluster of
histone modifications that are connected
to repression of the gene but among
these clusters we are still interested
in what really are the mechanistic
interactions because we think of the of
the mathematically direct interactions
is being the one that are biochemically
realized in the cell so this is the
matrix of partial correlation
coefficients and it's much sparser the
red is now the good ones and zero is
around here is to acquire so many many
entries here are near zero and we can
compute networks and then we get a
network than can hang that one can
actually look at and study and compared
to the biochemical information for
example here blue now means anti
correlation we have a thick blue line
for an anti correlation between the
activating mark and the repressive mark
this is exactly what I pointed out to
you based on
on the tracks of the individual
modifications also the math doesn't care
about where the data actually come from
I just included the levels of the
messenger RNA into the analysis just as
if it were a history fication although
it isn't but who cares yeah so the level
of the mRNA expression is inversely
proportional to the repressive mark and
positively correlated to the activating
mark just as it should be and then sort
of one can go through this and interpret
it like there's a whole cluster of other
acetylation here but it is interesting
to see that those are far away from
where the real regulatory activity is
and then we have pushed this father
there's also proteins that are
responsible for putting these chemical
moieties the histone modifications or
for removing them so there are enzymes
that actually do the processes and again
we have data for their presence in the
promoters and we are interested in which
of these interactions are really direct
because that's where the marrow
chemistry is so we did the same analysis
with a partial correlation coefficients
to combine enzymes like here this ph f8
or sous 12-2 modifications which are
here the rectangular rectangles so the
more biologically inclined will
recognize this for example is the famous
polycom complex where the that is made
up of a complex of ezh2 suz 12 and one
or two of these cbx proteins and this
complex sets the sh3 licen 27
trimethylation repressive mark so one
seized is immediately from the data here
and the other thing that one does is one
can compare of course to the literature
and all the solid lines here unknown
have been reported in the literature as
being real interactions that the dashed
lines here are not known so I
collaborator
which was Hong Kong also in our
Institute set out to verify these
experimentally because the method was
really suggesting that there should be
an interaction between this age for less
than 20 mono methylation and these two
proteins here which was not known and
this actually to the biologists fairly
surprising and when one does the
experiments one can really verify this
so there's new knowledge that is coming
out of this type of data analysis
nevertheless I i do want to point out
that the machinery that I was
summarizing for you is not limited to
these biological applications i did a
little bit of google scholar searching
and here we have on the inverse of the
covariance matrix in portfolio analysis
in the journal of finance or we have
partial correlation for functional brain
something in functional MRI neuroimage
biological cybernetics bioinformatics as
i was talking about so it's all over the
place and it essentially always the same
machinery it's very nicely described all
of this in the book by hast egyptia
running treatment elements of
statistical learning but even there i'd
only made it into the book in a second
edition the first edition did not yet
contained out the second edition has a
chapter 17 i think which herbs which
summarizes what I was just talking about
two people from my Institute a couple
years back I wrote a very nice review
where some of this can be read and this
is the the pointer to our work where we
have used it on it on a data situation
that is more amenable to this type of
analysis and with this I'm done and I
thank you for your attention
it's totally violated what we've done in
our own work is a few years back we used
rank transformation so we rank transform
the data which means that you compute a
rank correlation coefficient and the
rank partial correlation coefficient and
that partly takes care of it and
actually this is also one of our current
research activities how we can
generalize all this to to become
independent of the Gaussian assumption
so my hope is that within a week there
will be a paper on archive with our
answer to this but it has bothered us a
lot and we spent quite some energy on
this but I didn't want to make it a
topic for this presentation here
yeah I it does i mean when when we look
at the data the partial correlations
tell us i think you need a lot but about
the causality you have to assume that
you have more or less complete data yeah
that the really the physically
interacting variables are present in
your data and if that is the case then
you can ask if i have a coordination
that gets explained away by another
variable usually that really has to do
with biochemistry that is going on there
yeah e we are now currently
experimenting with Bayesian networks on
the one hand but there's also very
interesting paper by peter Bulman where
he combines Bayesian networks with Judea
polls do calculus to determine the
direction on the arrows and what we have
what we are again currently doing back
in Berlin is we are using the histone
modification data to test all this
machinery because for the histone
modification data we have this
classification into readers writers and
the erasers so we have bio chemical
knowledge about the direction of the
arrow of the causality and so we are
using now it is the ID a method it's
called from petaluma on this data and
trying to understand in how far it is
possible to recover the what we know
about a logical short answer is about
two-thirds of the directions we get
right is that statistically significant
hard to say we only have this one
example
we'll see other we are still working on
that they are not concurrent they are
there's a there's a whole literature on
this that you can construct terribly
contrived cases where where the partial
correlations have the opposite sign of
the correlations it gets very confusing
you cannot rely on those on the sign of
these to give you sort of the the
intuitive answer there is a book that's
called path analysis and something I can
look it up for you which which goes
through all these contrived examples and
warns you one of the reasons actually to
move over to the inverse of the variance
covariance matrix and to the shrinkage
methods to estimate this is that the
partial correlation coefficient in
itself is numerically very unstable
because if you have if you have vectors
where two of them are highly correlated
then you start to two in the definition
of the partial correlation you are
nearly singularity so it's medically
extremely difficult for a large set of
vectors to compute this and that's
that's much of the reason why we need
these shrinkage methods otherwise the
the naive computation just goes off into
space somewhere
it's an interesting thought yeah I need
to think about this maybe we talked
about it one of these days it's an
interesting idea i haven't linked it in
my to be honest yeah i believe so yes
well we kind of work under the
assumption that promoters tend to be
similar to each other but there are
other parts of the genome we have
another paper that appeared recently in
cell reports where where we did the
segmentation and we did networks for
each type of region so there is a
network for enhancers and there's a
networker promoters and then of course
you see somewhat different networks
which i think again reflect a biological
function of these individual regions I
haven't there I never dare to go into
heterogeneity within one type of region